also in washington a new congressional  report finds more cases of baby food  with high levels of dangerous toxic  metals and now lawmakers are calling on  the fda to crack down on product  regulation some companies are taking  things into their own hands though  nature's one for example says its  ingredients are tested heavily before  they even reach the building  we were the poster child for the first  toxins  identified in certain ingredients  representative there from nature one and  because of that experience nature's one  says it has built itself back up through  advanced testing and transparency and it  hopes to push that wisdom off on other  major brands that are now in the  spotlight for their ingredients